This is 99% invisible, 9 Roman Mars. If you're standing on the sidewalk in the New York financial district, in the shadows of glass skyscrapers, you definitely don't feel like you're at the seaside. But head a few blocks south and suddenly you're at the edge of the continent, looking out at the water. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. There are docks and seagulls, and fairy boats ready to take you island hopping. Writer Paul Greenberg moved into an apartment down here over a decade ago.
这里是 99% invisible，我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你站在纽约金融区的行人道上，在玻璃摩天大楼的阴影下，你绝对不会觉得自己身处海滨。但只要往南走几个街区，你突然就来到了大陆的边缘，眺望着波光粼粼的水面。那是制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。那里有码头、海鸥，还有随时准备带你开启跳岛游的渡轮。作家保罗·格林伯格十多年前搬到了这里的一处公寓。
And up until that point, like a lot of New Yorkers, I didn't really pay that much attention to the sea. If I wanted to go to the ocean, I would go to Martha's Vineyard or Long Island. But then he started noticing all these maritime buildings, like the old Fulton Fish Market, where fishermen used to sell their catch to restaurants. I suddenly was sort of confronted with the fact that New York Manhattan is really a very ocean-y kind of place. Greenberg actually writes about the ocean for a living.
在此之前，和许多纽约人一样，我其实并没有对大海给予太多关注。如果我想去海边，我会去玛莎葡萄园岛或长岛。但随后，他开始注意到所有这些海事建筑，比如旧富尔顿鱼市，渔民们以前在那里把捕获的海鲜卖给餐馆。我突然意识到，纽约曼哈顿其实是一个非常具有海洋气息的地方。格林伯格实际上以写海洋为生。
His most recent book is called American Catch. And he started to research the relationship between New York City and the sea. But then, in 2012, something happened that made that relationship impossible to ignore. Hurricane Sandy crashing on shore wins now at 90 miles per hour and this storm is so big, so vast, 60 million Americans will feel its power. Just south of the Sasserie Sea Park, take a look out here. That is the Brooklyn Bridge and look at how those winds are whipping the river around. The river around. Hurricane Sandy's storm surge inundated neighborhoods throughout New York City. Sea water poured into the streets, flooding out apartment buildings and filling the subway tunnels.
他最近的一本书名为《美国之获》。他开始研究纽约市与海洋之间的关系。然而，在2012年，发生了一件事，让这种关系变得无法忽视。桑迪飓风狂暴登陆，风速达到每小时90英里，这场风暴如此巨大、辽阔，60万美国人将感受到它的威力。就在巴特里公园南面，看看这里。那是布鲁克林大桥，看看那些狂风是如何把河水搅得天翻地覆的。河水……桑迪飓风的风暴潮淹没了纽约市的各个街区。海水涌入街道，淹没了公寓楼，灌满了地铁隧道。
Greenberg and his family waited out the storm in their 10th floor apartment. We sat there and the storm hit and things started to rock and roll and then everything went black. Sandy knocked out power across Lower Manhattan. The day after I immediately wanted to get a sense of what it was like. So he walked down to the waterfront, passed a bunch of bars and restaurants. And when you peered in the windows, it looked as if there had been a horrible bar fight. Because the water had come in, flooded up to eight or nine feet,
格林伯格和他的家人在他们位于10楼的公寓里熬过了这场风暴。我们坐在那里，风暴来袭，东西开始摇晃，接着一切都陷入黑暗。桑迪切断了曼哈顿下城的电力。风暴过后的第二天，我立刻想去感受一下当时的情况。于是他走到海滨，路过了一串酒吧和餐馆。当你透过窗户往里看时，那景象就像刚发生了一场可怕的酒吧斗殴。因为水灌了进来，淹到了八九英尺高，
and thrown all the chairs and tables up in the air. But as he surveyed the damage, Greenberg also started to notice things about his neighborhood that he never had before. Turns out that Broadway, and I live on Broadway, is a ridge line. It's the high point between East and West, and when Hurricane Sandy hit Lower Manhattan, it got safer and safer and drier and drier, the closer you were up to Broadway.
把所有的桌椅都掀到了空中。但在察看灾情的同时，格林伯格也开始注意到他的街区一些他以前从未留意过的事情。原来百老汇大道——而我就住在百老汇大道上——是一条山脊线。它是东西方之间的高点，当桑迪飓风袭击曼哈顿下城时，你离百老汇越近，情况就越安全，越干燥。
He says the storm forced New Yorkers to see the relationship between their city and the ocean in a much more intimate way. Nothing equates you with your city's topography like living in the eye of a hurricane and feeling that water flow up and rise up and literally start to swallow the city. Sandy took the lives of over 100 people in the United States and caused upwards of 50 billion dollars in damage. It was the second most expensive storm in U.S.
他说，这场风暴迫使纽约人以一种更加亲密的方式看待他们的城市与海洋之间的关系。没有什么能比身处飓风眼中、感受着水流漫溢上升并几乎开始吞噬这座城市，更能让你深刻体会到你所在城市的微观地形了。桑迪在美国夺去了100多人的生命，并造成了高达500亿美元的损失。这是美国历史上代价第二高的风暴。
history. And part of the reason why the storm was so destructive has to do with climate change. Scientists have calculated that because of sea level rise driven by climate change, Sandy flooded in additional 27 square miles and affected 83,000 more people than it would have otherwise. There is a wake-up call here and there is a lesson to be learned. This is Governor Andrew Cuomo speaking in the storms after math. There was a reality that has existed for a long time that we have been blind to and that is climate change, extreme weather, call it what you will and our vulnerability to it.
这场风暴之所以如此具有破坏性，部分原因与气候变化有关。科学家计算过，由于气候变化推动的海平面上升，桑迪多淹没了27平方英里的土地，并比原本多影响了83,000人。这是一个警钟，也是一个需要吸取的教训。这是州长安德鲁·库默在风暴过后发表的讲话。长期以来一直存在着一个我们一直视而不见的现实，那就是气候变化、极端天气——随你怎么称呼它——以及我们对它的脆弱性。
It's undeniable but that the frequency of extreme weather conditions is up. So it's going to be a rethinking, redesign of how we protect this metropolitan area from this increased frequency. Architects and engineers are looking at different ways that cities like New York can redesign their infrastructure to prepare for more extreme storm surges. There's talk of floodgates and massive seawalls that would stretch across the entire harbor. But Paul Greenberg says that one of the solutions for New York's future might lie in its past.
不可否认的是，极端天气条件的发生频率正在上升。因此，我们需要重新思考和重新设计如何保护这个大都市区免受这种日益频繁的灾害的影响。建筑师和工程师们正在寻找不同的方法，让纽约这样的城市能够重新设计其基础设施，以应对更极端的风暴潮。有人在讨论建造防洪闸和横跨整个港口的巨大海堤。但保罗·格林伯格表示，纽约未来的解决方案之一可能存在于它的过去。
Well, so New York, in its natural state, was set up to deal with big storms. New York was built at the mouth of Hudson River, and that fertile estuary environment was filled with all kinds of marine life. But one majestic creature, in particular, shaped the landscape. It's estimated probably in the trillions of oysters surrounded New York City. Before European colonization, what we now think of as the New York City Harbor was a
嗯，所以纽约在其自然状态下，是为了应对大风暴而存在的。纽约建在哈德逊河口，那个肥沃的河口环境里充满了各种海洋生物。但其中有一种雄伟的生物，尤其塑造了这里的地貌。据估计，曾有数以万亿美元计的牡蛎环绕着纽约市。在欧洲殖民之前，我们现在所知的纽约港曾是一个
veritable oyster kingdom. Some scientists think it contained nearly half the world's oysters, and they were an important part of the ecosystem. Oistors are filter feeders, and they help keep bacteria levels in check. And in addition to their ability to filter the water, oysters did a huge amount to buffer the city against storm surges because oysters are kind of special. They are unique among mollusks in that they build in three dimensions.
真正的牡蛎王国。一些科学家认为它包含了世界上近一半的牡蛎，它们是生态系统的重要组成部分。牡蛎是滤食性动物，它们有助于将细菌水平控制在合理范围内。除了净化水质的能力外，牡蛎在缓冲城市免受风暴潮侵袭方面也发挥了巨大作用，因为牡蛎有某种特殊之处。它们在软体动物中是独一无二的，因为它们是以三维方式构建的。
So they're really architects in a sense. Oysters like to grow on top of other oysters. They actually sense the chemical basicness of oyster shell and they will see directly on top of other oysters. So you get these aggregations, these clumps that build, build, build, and build. And eventually they build up into massive complex reef structures, kind of like coral reefs. Well, oysters really are the coral reefs of temperate zones. Oyster reefs covered over 220,000 acres in the Hudson River estuary, and sometimes
从某种意义上说，它们确实是建筑师。牡蛎喜欢在其他牡蛎的上面生长。它们实际上能感知到牡蛎壳的化学碱性，并会直接在其他牡蛎上面安家落户。因此，你会看到这些聚集体、这些不断生长、生长、再生长的团块。最终它们会长成巨大的复杂礁石结构，有点像珊瑚礁。嗯，牡蛎确实是温带地区的珊瑚礁。牡蛎礁曾经覆盖了哈德逊河河口超过22万英亩的土地，有时
they grew as high as 20 feet tall. Like coral reefs, they cut down on coastal erosion, and were home to all different kinds of fish. And just as coral reefs help protect many tropical islands from hurricanes, oysters protected New York City. They broke up large waves before they could crash onto the shore. And below the surface, their rough texture would increase friction and slow down the water. And so, an oyster reef spread out over many miles will actually sap the wave energy of waves passing over it. Most people don't associate New York City with oysters today, but back in the 1700s, they were what New York was known for.
它们的高度甚至能长到20英尺。就像珊瑚礁一样，它们减少了海岸侵蚀，并且是各种不同鱼类的家园。正如珊瑚礁帮助许多热带岛屿抵御飓风一样，牡蛎也保护了纽约市。它们在巨浪冲上海岸之前将其打碎。在水面以下，它们粗糙的纹理会增加摩擦力并减缓水流。因此，绵延数英里的牡蛎礁实际上会消耗流经它的海浪的能量。今天大多数人不会将纽约市与牡蛎联系在一起，但在18世纪，纽约正是以牡蛎闻名的。
Oysters were absolutely central to the identity of New York. If somebody were to say I'm going to New York, they would say enjoy the oysters. This is Mark Kirlansky, author of many books, including an environmental history of New York City called The Big Oyster. Kralanski says that before colonization, the indigenous Lenape people ate lots of oysters. And when the Dutch arrived in the area, they found an oyster paradise. You know, you could just walk down to the shore
牡蛎绝对是纽约身份的核心。如果有人说我要去纽约，人们就会说去享受牡蛎吧。这是马克·科兰斯基，他著有多本书籍，包括一本关于纽约市环境史的书《大牡蛎》。科兰斯基说，在殖民之前，土著勒纳佩人吃大量的牡蛎。当荷兰人来到这个地区时，他们发现了一个牡蛎天堂。你知道，你只要走到岸边，
anywhere, certainly in Lower Manhattan, where everybody was living, but anywhere, and break off a few oysters to eat. And that's exactly what they did. Everybody in New York ate oysters. We said that the only thing that poor people ever got to eat was oysters and bread, but it was also something that rich people ate.
任何地方，当然是在每个人都居住的曼哈顿下城，但随便哪个地方，都可以敲下一些牡蛎来吃。而这正是他们所做的。纽约的每个人都吃牡蛎。我们常说穷人唯一能吃到的东西就是牡蛎和面包，但这也是富人吃的东西。
Kind of unusual in food history to have and rich people food and the poor people food be the same at the same time. Oysters were sold in street carts and bars, but also fancy restaurants, and they were served in all different kinds of ways. Oh, there were lots of things. They were like oyster loaves and oysters with different kinds of sauces and they were oyster stews.
在食物史上，富人吃的食物和穷人吃的食物在同一时间是同一种东西，这有点不寻常。牡蛎在街头小推车和酒吧里出售，但也出现在高档餐厅里，它们有各种各样的烹饪方式。哦，有太多做法了。比如牡蛎面包、配有各种酱汁的牡蛎，还有牡蛎炖菜。
Discarded oyster shells piled up in huge mounds outside of shocking houses and restaurants. They were so plentiful that builders began using oysters as construction material. Shells were burned to create lime, ground up for mortar, or used to pave streets. For instance, Pearl Street in Lower Manhattan is called Pearl Street because it was originally paved with crushed oyster shells. The demand for oysters was so great that it eventually outstripped New York's bountiful supply. The Erie Canal and the railroad opened up new markets.
被丢弃的牡蛎壳在剥壳厂和餐馆外面堆成了巨大的小山。它们是如此丰富，以至于建筑商开始将牡蛎用作建筑材料。贝壳被烧制成石灰，磨碎用作砂浆，或者用来铺设街道。例如，曼哈顿下城的珍珠街之所以叫珍珠街，是因为它最初是用压碎的牡蛎壳铺成的。对牡蛎的需求如此巨大，以至于最终超出了纽约丰饶的供应量。伊利运河和铁路开辟了新的市场。
Well, a nature could not produce enough oysters for it near all the places. Once they were shipping them to a lot of places, it was more than the natural beds could provide. By the mid-1800s, New York's natural oyster population had been depleted. Humans had nearly eaten the city's protective shellfish barrier out of existence. But that wasn't the end of oysters in New York. When they started to run out of oysters in New York City, they went and got seeded from
嗯，大自然无法为所有这些地方生产足够的牡蛎。一旦开始将它们运往许多地方，就超过了天然牡蛎床所能提供的数量。到19世纪中叶，纽约的天然牡蛎种群已经枯竭。人类几乎把这座城市起保护作用的贝类屏障吃得不复存在。但这并不是纽约牡蛎故事的结束。当纽约市的牡蛎开始耗尽时，他们便去寻找并获取来自
the Chesapeake Bay. And they planted these baby oysters on long ropes, strung in rows throughout the shallows of the harbor. Farming oysters works quite well, and it is kind of the next logical step, you know, if you need more oysters than grow there with nature, you just grow some of yourself. Oyster farming continued throughout the 19th century, and by the 1880s the city was producing over 700 million oysters per year, but there was a problem lurking in the water. For years the city had been dumping industrial pollutants and sewage straight into the harbour without a second thought.
切萨皮克湾的种苗。他们把这些小牡蛎种在长绳上，一排排悬挂在港口浅滩的各处。养殖牡蛎非常奏效，这可以说是顺理成章的下一步，你知道，如果你需要的牡蛎超过了自然生长的数量，你只需自己养殖一些即可。牡蛎养殖在整个19世纪持续进行，到19世纪80年代，该市每年生产超过7亿只牡蛎，但水质中潜伏着一个问题。多年来，这座城市一直毫不迟疑地将工业污染物和污水直接倾倒到港口中。
It didn't seem to register with people that dumping raw sewage on a food supply would be unhealthy. It seemed sort of intuitive to me, but they didn't worry about that. That is until the early 1900s, when New York was hit with deadly outbreaks of cholera and typhoid. Public health officials were able to track the diseases back to the source. Turned out that most of these epidemics
人们似乎并没有意识到向食物供应源倾倒生污水是不健康的。这对我来说似乎很直观，但他们并不担心这一点。直到20世纪初，纽约爆发了致命的霍乱和伤寒疫情。公共卫生官员顺藤摸瓜，查清了这些疾病的源头。原来，这些流行病大多
were coming from oyster beds. And so one by one, the city started shutting down the oyster beds. Which was really upsetting for New Yorkers. It was huge front page news every time they closed an oyster bed. And there would be all these articles about how we have to do something about this. We're losing our heritage, we're losing our oysters, and we have to stop this. But they somehow didn't get it stopped. New York closed its last remaining oyster bed
都源自牡蛎床。于是，这座城市开始一个接一个地关闭牡蛎床。这让纽约人感到非常沮丧。每次关闭一个牡蛎床，都会成为头版头条的大新闻。会有各种各样的文章讨论我们必须为此做点什么。我们在失去传统，我们在失去牡蛎，我们必须制止这种行为。但不知为何，他们没能阻止这一切。纽约关闭了其最后一个剩下的牡蛎床，
off the South Coast of Staten Island in 1927. Water quality continued to deteriorate until oysters could no longer survive. The water was so acidic, it would actually etch through the shelves. By the middle of the 20th century, New York's world-famous oysters were all but gone, leaving the sea-bottom baron and the city exposed. Pollution continues to be a problem in New York, but in 1972, Congress passed the Clean Water Act, which regulated the waste being dumped into waterways, and little by little, water
位于史泰登岛南海岸，时间是1927年。水质持续恶化，直到牡蛎再也无法生存。水质呈高度酸性，甚至会腐蚀贝壳。到了20世纪中叶，纽约世界闻名的牡蛎几乎消失殆尽，导致海底荒芜，城市暴露在外。污染继续成为纽约的一个问题，但在1972年，国会通过了《清洁水法》，对排入水道的废物进行了监管，港口的水质也一点点
quality in the harbor has improved. Now oxygen levels are high enough to support shelters, so theoretically, we could have shelters again throughout the bay. This is Paul Greenberg again. In his book, American Catch, he documents several different groups who are working really hard to try and bring back the New York Oyster. There are a lot of obstacles in their way, including FDA rules, which make it really hard to plant oysters, and the fact that there just isn't enough wild oyster larvae in the water anymore. But one of the biggest challenges is actually an architectural one, because the physical landscape of the harbor has totally changed. We've been dredging the harbor for over 150 years now. It went from an average depth of 20
有所改善。现在氧气含量已经高到足以支持贝类生存，因此从理论上讲，我们整个海湾都可以再次拥有贝类。这是保罗·格林伯格。在他的书《美国之获》中，他记录了几个致力于让纽约牡蛎重焕生机的不同群体。他们面临着许多障碍，包括美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的规定，这些规定使得种植牡蛎变得异常困难，而且水中确实已经没有足够的野生牡蛎幼虫了。但其中最大的挑战实际上是建筑学上的，因为港口的物理景观已经发生了彻底的改变。我们对港口进行疏浚已经有150多年的历史了。它的平均深度从
feet to places where now it's more than 50 feet, and the bottom looks very different. Right now our harbor has a flat muddy bottom, but if we were to look at, say, 1850, 1880, this would have been an extremely kind of rougher, three-dimensional mosaic. This is Kate Orf. She's a landscape architect and founder of the firm Scape, based in Manhattan.
20英尺变成了现在有些地方超过50英尺，海底看起来也大不相同了。目前我们的港口有着平坦的泥泞海底，但如果我们回看1850年、1880年左右，这里将是一个非常粗糙的三维马赛克景观。这是凯特·奥尔夫。她是一位景观设计师，也是总部位于曼哈顿的Scape事务所的创始人。
And she's the author of the new book Towards an Urban Ecology. She also just became the first landscape architect to win a MacArthur Genius Award. And Orp says that a flat muddy bottom just does not work well for oysters. There are no places or very few places for oysters to grab onto and to attach. Right now, there are some oyster larvae floating around out there, but they don't really stand a chance. Any oyster that lands on the bottom of the bay's bed will then immediately be covered with soap. So we need to lift those oysters off of the bay floor, and we need to provide substrate for these creatures to attach onto.
她也是新书《走向城市生态》的作者。她最近还成为了第一位获得麦克阿瑟天才奖的景观设计师。奥尔夫表示，平坦的泥泞海底根本不适合牡蛎生长。牡蛎没有地方或者只有极少的地方可以抓附。目前，有一些牡蛎幼虫在水中漂浮，但它们并没有真正的生存机会。任何降落在海湾底部的牡蛎都会立刻被淤泥覆盖。因此，我们需要将这些牡蛎从海底托举起来，并为这些生物提供附着的基质。
That challenge gave Orphan idea that spawned one of my favorite portmanteaus, oyster texture. The concept was to build giant nets made of fuzzy marine rope and elevate them off the sea floor. They would then seed the nets with oyster larvae and let the oysters grow from there. So it agglomerates in the sense of becoming a mega structure that scales up out of very small organisms. With a relatively small architectural intervention, you could have a new piece of protective infrastructure, an artificial oyster reef, which in turn would filter the water, slow the water, and create a safer relationship with that water.
这一挑战给了奥尔夫一个灵感，催生了我最喜欢的混成词之一：牡蛎纹理（oyster-tecture）。这个概念是建造由毛茸茸的海洋绳索制成的巨大网，并将它们从海底悬浮起来。然后，他们会在网上播种牡蛎幼虫，让牡蛎从那里生长。所以它在成为一个从微小生物扩大规模的巨型结构的意义上是聚合的。通过一个相对较小的建筑干预，你就可以拥有一个新的保护性基础设施，即人造牡蛎礁，进而可以过滤水、减缓水流，并与这些水建立更安全的关系。
Kate Orf debuted her oyster texture proposal in 2010, as part of an exhibit at the Museum of Modern Art called Rising Currents. And it was a speculative project that sparked a ton of conversation, but it was never actually built. But Hurricane Sandy brought new attention to sea level rise and opened new funding avenues for coastal resilience projects. In 2013, the federal government launched its Hurricane Sandy Rebuilding Task Force and staged an architectural competition called Rebuild by Design. Escape, that's Kate Orf's Architecture firm,
凯特·奥尔夫在2010年首次推出了她的“牡蛎纹理”提案，作为现代艺术博物馆一个名为“不断上涨的海平面”展览的一部分。这是一个引发了大量讨论的投机性项目，但从未真正建造过。然而，桑迪飓风让人们重新关注海平面上升，并为海岸韧性项目开辟了新的资金渠道。2013年，联邦政府成立了“桑迪飓风重建工作组”，并举办了一场名为“通过设计重建”的建筑竞赛。Scape，也就是凯特·奥尔夫的建筑事务所，
submitted an Oyster-centric proposal called Living Breakwaters. The project receives $60 million of funding and will be carried out by the governor's office of storm recovery. Now, Scape is in the process of designing artificial oyster reef breakwaters off the South Coast of Staten Island. Staten Island was particularly hard hit by Hurricane Sandy. This is Gina Worth, another one of the architects from Scape, explaining the choice of location. And the wave action from the surge landed right on Staten Island and
提交了一个以牡蛎为中心的提案，名为“活生生的防波堤”。该项目获得了6000万美元的资金，并将由州长办公室的灾后恢复办公室执行。现在，Scape正在设计位于史泰登岛南海岸的人造牡蛎礁防波堤。史泰登岛在桑迪飓风中受灾尤为严重。这是吉娜·沃思，Scape的另一位建筑师，她解释了选址的原因。风暴潮带来的海浪直接冲击了史泰登岛，
really dramatically impacted this land mass. Staten Island was also one of the epicenters of New York's historic oyster economy. So it's not the first time that people have been trying to cultivate and expand oysters within the bay. Hundreds of years ago, they were doing it for food production, and today we're trying to do it for a more robust and resilient shoreline. The design has evolved a lot from the original
并对这片陆地造成了巨大的破坏。史泰登岛也曾是纽约历史上牡蛎经济的发源地之一。因此，这并不是人们第一次试图在海湾内培育和扩展牡蛎。几百年前，他们这样做是为了生产食物，而今天我们试图这样做是为了建立一个更强健、更有弹性的海岸线。这个设计已经从最初的
oyster texture proposal with the marine rope. The plan now is to build a necklace of offshore breakwaters out of large rocks and a special material called eco concrete which shellfish like to grow on. They will then seed the breakwaters with oysters so they grow into reefs. Much like a natural oyster reef, the living breakwaters are designed to slow down the water and break up dangerous waves before they reach the shore. As the oysters grow, they really help add friction to the water column and break waves.
带有海洋绳索的“牡蛎纹理”提案演变了很多。现在的计划是用大块岩石和一种贝类喜欢在上面生长的被称为生态混凝土的特殊材料，在近海建造一串防波堤。然后，它们会在防波堤上播种牡蛎，使其长成礁石。就像天然牡蛎礁一样，“活生生的防波堤”旨在减缓水流，并在危险海浪到达海岸之前将其打碎。随着牡蛎的生长，它们确实有助于增加水体的摩擦力并打碎海浪。
The living breakwaters should reduce coastal erosion, build up beaches, and make storms less dangerous. Modeling by scientists at the Stevens Institute has shown that the breakwaters could have reduced the height of waves during sandy by 3 to 6 feet, but they won't keep flood water out of Staten Island altogether, and they're not meant to. Breakwaters let the water through. We can reduce the wave action. We can reduce the intensity and the velocity of that water, but we live in a coastal edge.
“活生生的防波堤”应该能够减少海岸侵蚀，堆积海滩，并降低风暴的危险性。史蒂文斯理工学院科学家的建模表明，这些防波堤在桑迪飓风期间可以将浪高降低3到6英尺，但它们并不能完全将洪水挡在史泰登岛之外，而且它们的本意也不是为了这个。防波堤让水流通过。我们可以减少海浪冲击力。我们可以减小这些水流的强度和速度，但我们生活在海岸边缘。
And Worth wants to design a way to make that coastal edge safer and healthier, both for humans and for marine life. In addition to reducing waves and filtering the water, the living breakwaters will provide some of the habitat that oyster reefs once did. Staten islands' historic oyster reefs were filled with all these nooks and crannies where juvenile fish like the hide. With the help of marine biologists, the architects designed pockets within the breakwater structure. They call them reef streets.
沃思希望设计一种方法，让这个海岸边缘对人类和海洋生物来说都更安全、更健康。除了减少海浪和过滤水质外，“活生生的防波堤”还将提供牡蛎礁曾经提供的一些栖息地。史泰登岛历史上的牡蛎礁充满了各种各样的隐蔽角落和缝隙，幼鱼喜欢藏身其中。在海洋生物学家的帮助下，建筑师们在防波堤结构中设计了口袋。他们称之为“礁石街道”。
So within the reef streets, juvenile fish are able to come in to these kind of underwater canyons and feed in the street and shelter and hide from predators in the structure. Where says that as a landscape architect, your clients are usually people. But we're also trying to think about who are our underwater clients,
因此，在礁石街道内，幼鱼能够游进这些类似水下峡谷的地方，在街道中觅食，并在结构中庇护和躲避捕食者。沃思说，作为一名景观设计师，你的客户通常是人。但我们也在努力思考谁是我们的水下客户，
who are the fish species that might use this system. Like if you were a fish swimming in the water, what would look like a safe place? It's like a totally different mentality to have when designing than what a person looks for. Construction hasn't begun yet on the physical structure of the breakwater, but some of the oysters are already growing. What? Next, oysters growing over here. This is Asia-Salgato, a recent graduate of the New York Harbor School on Governor's Island.
哪些鱼类可能会使用这个系统。就像如果你是一条在水中游动的鱼，什么地方看起来像个安全的地方？这与人类在寻找东西时所采用的设计心态完全不同。防波堤的实体结构建设尚未开始，但一些牡蛎已经在生长了。什么？接下来，牡蛎在这里生长。这是亚洲萨尔加托，她是总督岛纽约港口学校的应届毕业生。
I'll use guys right here. The Harbor School runs a program called the Billion Oyster Project, which aims to restore oysters throughout the harbor, and in the process teach young New Yorkers all about the Marine ecosystem. Asia is standing next to a tank filled with white shells, soaking in harbor water. They're actually left leftover shells from restaurants. So we'll go around and we'll collect shell
我会直接用你们这里的。港口学校运营着一个名为“十亿牡蛎项目”的程序，旨在恢复整个港口内牡蛎的生长，并在这一过程中向年轻的纽约人传授有关海洋生态系统的知识。亚洲正站在一个装满白色贝壳的水箱旁，贝壳浸泡在港口的水中。这些实际上是餐馆吃剩的贝壳。所以我们会到处走动，收集贝壳
from different restaurants around the city. And on the surface of every shell, there are little oysters growing. You see all these big brown dots over here? Yeah. Those are all oysters. They look like little blobs of brown jelly, but if you get really close,
来自城市各地的不同餐馆。在每一个贝壳的表面，都有小牡蛎在生长。你看到这里所有这些大的棕色斑点了吗？是的。这些全都是牡蛎。它们看起来像一团团棕色的果冻，但如果你靠得足够近，
you can see the beginnings of a oyster. You can kind of tell them this one, this one has like stripes on it. That's how you know that's like its own shell slowly growing. Once it gets bigger, obviously it'll look like one of these shells, but it's getting there slowly. The billion oyster project is an official partner on the living break waters, meaning that millions of little brown balls of goo grown by young New Yorkers like Asia will soon be
你可以看到牡蛎的雏形。你可以分辨出来，这个，这个上面有条纹。这就是你怎么知道那是它自己的贝壳在慢慢生长。等它长大了，显然它就会看起来像这些贝壳中的一个，但它正在慢慢向那个方向发展。“十亿牡蛎项目”是“活生生的防波堤”的官方合作伙伴，这意味着由像亚洲这样的年轻纽约人培育的数百万个小棕色果冻球很快就会
protecting Staten Island. The governor's office of storm recovery is scheduled to begin construction of the living break waters in 2018. The billion oyster project will work with local high schools on Staten Island to monitor oyster growth over time. A healthy reef can grow very quickly, so we're very optimistic that by say 2025, we would have a pretty robust reef system going. robust reef system going. Kate Orf says that even if they're successful, they aren't going to return the coastal environment to the way it was before. No architect can do that. They're creating something totally new. Part ecosystem, part infrastructure.
保护史泰登岛。州长灾后恢复办公室计划于2018年开始建设“活生生的防波堤”。“十亿牡蛎项目”将与史泰登岛当地的高中合作，随着时间的推移监测牡蛎的生长情况。健康的礁石可以生长得非常快，所以我们非常乐观地认为，到2025年左右，我们将拥有一个相当健壮的礁石系统。健壮的礁石系统正在形成。凯特·奥尔夫说，即使他们成功了，他们也不会将海岸环境恢复到以前的样子。没有哪个建筑师能做到这一点。他们在创造全新之物。部分是生态系统，部分是基础设施。
And Orf hopes that they inspire other living infrastructure projects, but she doesn't think that oysters are going to save New York from climate change. There isn't any one solution to a problem so immense and complex. Researchers at the organization Climate Central recently ranked New York as the most vulnerable city in the United States to see level rise, with over 426,000 people living in zones that could face serious flooding by 2050. When you start projecting out further than 2050, the scale of the problem becomes hard, the phantom. It's really hard, frankly, to be optimistic.
奥尔夫希望它们能启发其他活体基础设施项目，但她并不认为牡蛎能把纽约从气候变化中拯救出来。面对如此巨大而复杂的灾难，没有任何单一的解决方案。“气候中心”组织的研究人员最近将纽约评为美国受海平面上升威胁最脆弱的城市，有超过426,000人生活在到2050年可能面临严重洪灾的地区。当你开始预测2050年以后时，问题的规模变得难以想象。坦率地说，要保持乐观真的很困难。
We're on track for pretty rapids, you know, level rise. Can we kind of come together and proactively see this as an urban design opportunity and not a force that just displaces thousands of people with less economic means and who are less fortunate? I don't know. I think it's going to be a real challenge. Orf sees the Living Breakwater's project as a step toward a healthier relationship between the city and the sea.
我们正在经历相当迅速的海平面上升。我们能否团结起来，积极地将其视为一个城市设计的机会，而不是一股仅仅流离失所了数千名经济条件较差、不那么幸运的人的力量？我不知道。我认为这将是一个真正的挑战。奥尔夫将“活生生的防波堤”项目视为迈向城市与海洋之间更健康关系的一步。
But to protect New York and other coastal cities in the long term, there are going to be a lot of other interventions that will need to be considered, ending new development on coasts, lifting existing buildings up, and eventually in some places. Retreating literally from floodprone areas and can we have those hard conversations? I certainly hope so. I hope so too because New York is a city by the ocean, and the water is only getting higher. Oysters aren't the only non-human architects, and that gives us a tour through the extraordinary builders of the animal kingdom. After this.
但为了长远保护纽约和其他沿海城市，还有许多其他的干预措施需要被考虑，比如叫停海岸线的新开发项目、垫高现有建筑，甚至在某些地方最终选择。从易受洪水侵袭的地区字面意义上撤退，我们能进行那些艰难的对话吗？我当然希望如此。我也希望如此，因为纽约是一座依海而建的城市，而水位只会越来越高。牡蛎并不是唯一的非人类建筑师，接下来就让我们带你游览动物王国中非凡的建筑师。广告之后见。
Okay, so I'm in the studio with Emmett Fitzgerald who just did that piece, and in the piece, you talk with Paul Greenberg, and he talks about oysters behaving like architects, because they build these massive structures in the shoreline. And it goes thinking about other types of architecture that is not made by humans. I mean, I think I feel like architecture and the building of structures and buildings is sometimes sort of thought about as something that separates humans from the beasts, but a lot of my favorite architects are animals. Okay, well, later on, I was told we put some.
好了，我和刚刚做了那篇报道的埃米特·菲茨杰拉德在录音室里，在报道中，你和保罗·格林伯格进行了交谈，他谈到了牡蛎表现得像建筑师一样，因为它们在海岸线上建造了这些巨大的结构。这让人想到了其他不是由人类建造的建筑。我的意思是，我觉得建筑以及结构和建筑物的建造有时被认为是将人类与野兽区分开来的东西，但我许多最喜欢的建筑师都是动物。好吧，稍后，听说我们准备了一些……
All right, so there's a lot of different examples of animal architecture, but let's try to do a couple from different animal kingdoms. So to start with the mammals, we've got to go with beavers, which are sort of, yeah, maybe the most, maybe the most obvious example, but they really are pretty special architects. First of all, they build these incredible houses, these lodges out of sticks and mud, and they've got these cool underwater entrances.
好吧，所以动物建筑有很多不同的例子，但让我们尝试从不同的动物王国中挑选几个。首先是哺乳动物，我们必须提到海狸，它们可以说是，是的，也许是最，也许是最明显的例子，但它们确实是非常特殊的建筑师。首先，它们用树枝和泥土建造这些令人难以置信的房屋，即它们的巢穴，并且它们拥有这些很酷的水下入口。
But more amazingly, they completely re-engineer the landscape by cutting down trees with their teeth and building these big dams that essentially will turn, you know, what's a river system into a peaceful pond for them to live in. And I was sort of looking into this and I found this one scientist think that they've discovered the largest beaver dam in the world in Northern Alberta, in Canada. And it's 2,790 feet long. Whoa. Which is, yeah, I mean, it's really big. That's like larger than, you know, human dams.
但更神奇的是，它们用牙齿砍倒树木并建造这些大水坝，从根本上彻底改造了地貌，基本上将一条河流系统变成了供它们居住的平静池塘。我对此进行了一些调查，我发现有一位科学家认为他们在加拿大北部艾伯塔省发现了世界上最大的海狸水坝。它有2,790英尺长。哇。这，是的，我的意思是，它真的很大。这比，你知道的人类水坝还要大。
That's large in the Hoover Dam. Right. And yeah, they think that this was built, many, over like multiple generations of beavers, different families contributing to this massive dam to create sort of a little beaver paradise up there in Alberta. Well, I would think it would take generations to do that. That's remarkable.
这比胡佛水坝还要大。没错。是的，他们认为这是由多代海狸建造的，历经多代，不同的家庭为这个巨大的水坝做出了贡献，在那里，在艾伯塔省创造了一个小小的海狸天堂。嗯，我想这需要好几代人的努力才能做到。这太了不起了。
All right, so what's next? All right, so moving on to insects. There are tons of great examples of insect architects, you know, bees, ants, but I'm gonna go with termites for this one. Termites build, you know, these giant mounds out of mud. You can find them all over the world, really,
好吧，接下来是什么？好的，接下来转向昆虫。昆虫建筑师有成千上万个绝佳的例子，你知道的，蜜蜂、蚂蚁，但我这次要选白蚁。白蚁用泥土建造了，你知道的，这些巨大的土堆。你在世界各地都能找到它们，真的，
and a lot of dry climates in Africa, and Australia, and South America. And these can get huge. They can be upwards of like 30 feet tall. And really wide too, they're like these really, really, really large structures. And if you think about that relative to the size of a termite's body, it's like even more impressive. I mean, a 30 foot tall structure for a termite, if you sort of scaled that up to our size, it would be something like close to a mile high.
以及非洲、澳大利亚和南美洲的许多干燥气候区。这些土堆可以变得非常巨大。它们的高度可以达到30英尺以上。而且也非常宽，它们就像这些真的、真的、非常大的结构。如果你考虑到这一点相对于白蚁体型的比例，这就更令人印象深刻了。我的意思是，对于一只白蚁来说，一个30英尺高的结构，如果你把它按比例放大到我们的大小，它将接近一英里高。
So they really are building incredible skyscrapers. Sky's great, but my favorite thing about termite mounds, really though, is that they exist really to provide ventilation to the termite colony. So the colony exists even underground and spreads out beneath over a greater distance than just the termite colony. So the colony exists even underground and spreads out beneath, you know, over a greater distance than just the termite mound, but it can get really, really hot underground, especially in these dry climates. And so they'll build this structure upwards, and it's super porous. And so cool breezes will catch the termite mound, and it's built in such a way that it
所以它们确实在建造令人难以置信的摩天大楼。摩天大楼，但说实话，我最喜欢白蚁土堆的地方在于，它们的存在实际上是为了给白蚁群体提供通风。因此，这个群体甚至存在于地下，并且在地下蔓延的距离比单纯的白蚁土堆还要广大。因此，这个群体甚至存在于地下，并且在地下蔓延的距离，你知道的，比单纯的白蚁土堆还要远，但在地下可能会变得非常非常热，特别是在这些干燥的气候中。因此，它们会向上建造这个结构，而且它是超级多孔的。所以凉爽的微风会吹进白蚁土堆，它的建造方式使得它
ventilates the entire colony and keeps them, it helps them regulate their temperature. Which is just a pretty amazing level of innovation for a tiny insect. So you shouldn't think about these things as just being a mound of dirt that they then dig in and just live in. It really is a purpose-built solution to solve a certain problem. Right, exactly. That's remarkable. Yeah, and the same could be said about lots of different animals. And obviously, it's a little different because it's not a single person who has an idea,
能够为整个群落通风，并使它们保持温度，帮助它们调节体温。对于一只小小的昆虫来说，这简直是令人惊叹的创新水平。所以你不应该认为这些东西只是一堆土，它们在里面挖洞并住在里面。它确实是一个为了解决某个特定问题而专门建造的解决方案。没错，完全正确。这太了不起了。是的，许多不同的动物也可以这么说。显然，这有点不同，因为这不是一个有想法的单个个体，
it's like solution to a problem. It's like an evolutionary solution, like an adaptation that they developed over a long period of time. But that doesn't make it any less remarkable to me. Totally, I don't know me either. That's amazing. Okay, so what's our last one? All right, so this is, our last one is my personal favorite, really just for like the artistry of it,
它就像是解决问题的方法。它就像是一个进化的解决方案，就像它们在漫长的时间里发展出来的适应能力。但这对我来说并没有因此减少一分惊奇。完全同意，我也一样。这太神奇了。好吧，那我们的最后一个是什么？好的，所以这是，我们的最后一个是我个人最喜欢的，真的只是因为它的艺术性，
but there's this bird in that lives in the forest of New Guinea called the Vagol Cop Powerbird. It was a few different power birds, but the Vagol Cop is my personal favorite, and it's this totally unassuming looking bird. It's like a little brown looks kind of like a sparrow. So it's this unassuming bird, but the male Bauerbird in order to get females attention, they will spend several years building these elaborate structures called Bauer's and they're really, they're so beautiful. They're
但在新几内亚的森林里有一种鸟，叫做沙氏亭鸟（Vogelkop Bowerbird）。有几种不同的亭鸟，但沙氏亭鸟是我个人最喜欢的，它是一种看起来毫不起眼的鸟。它有点像一只小棕鸟，长得有点像麻雀。所以它是这种不起眼的鸟，但是雄性亭鸟为了吸引雌性的注意，会花好几年的时间建造这些被称为“求偶亭”的精心结构，它们真的，太美了。它们是
like these beautiful, fat tents that they construct using little twigs and sticks, but they're so carefully done if you came across one in the forest, you wouldn't even consider that a bird made that. It looks like it was designed by little fairy architects or something. And yeah, and then often they'll be carpeted with a mossy carpet. The front is propped up with two sticks at the entrance. And then they're decorated in these crazy ways. They'll go and get flowers and build little piles of flowers. They'll get berries, all kinds of especially things that are colorful to add color to the
就像这些美丽的、胖乎乎的帐篷，它们用小枝条和树枝建造，但它们做得如此仔细，如果你在森林里偶然发现一个，你甚至不会认为那是鸟类建造的。它看起来像是被某个小仙女建筑师或者别的什么设计的。而且，是的，它们通常会铺上苔原般的绿毯。入口处用两根棍子支撑着。然后它们以这种疯狂的方式进行装饰。它们会去寻找并堆积一小堆花朵。它们会弄来浆果，各种各样色彩斑斓的东西，为
bowler. And then it's all of this, all of this years of building work is all just for this one moment when they're attempting to catch the eye of female bowerbirds who are looking to mate. And so the female will come in and there might be like more than one of these bours in a given part of the forest and shall like decide who her favorite architect is and mate with that bours version. All right well thanks for giving us a guide to animal architects. Yeah my pleasure. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mix and tech production by Sri Fusif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of
求偶亭增添色彩。然后，这一切，所有这些多年的建造工作，都只是为了这一个时刻，当它们试图吸引正在寻找配偶的雌性亭鸟的目光时。所以雌性会走进来，森林的某个特定部分可能会有不止一个这样的求偶亭，它会决定谁是她最喜欢的建筑师，并与那个求偶亭的版本进行交配。好吧，谢谢你为我们提供动物建筑师指南。不客气，我的荣幸。本周的 99% Invisible 由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，混音和技术制作由斯里·富西夫（Sri Fusif）负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Rial）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是资深制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、艾弗里·特鲁凡（Avery Truffan）、泰伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街（Radio Row）制作。99% Invisible 是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。我们得到了奈特基金会和听众捐赠者的支持，他们竭尽所能帮助我们继续制作
the team includes Delaney Hall, Avery Truffan, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. We are supported by the night foundation and listener donors who pitch in whatever they can to keep us making
世界上最好的音频。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，以及@节目 @99PI org，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也可以找到我们。但是如果你在想，我的生活需要更多 99PI。我们所有的旧剧集都可以在我们精美的网站上找到，每隔几天就会有关于设计的新文章。网址是 99
the best audio in the world. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you are thinking, I need some more 99PI in my life. We have all the old episodes available and new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful website. It's 99 and new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful website. It's 99pi.org.
pi.org。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。